so what is the fastest free scientific
programming language between some of the
most popular python octave and fortran
well one benchmark you can check is to
implement the doodle algorithm which is
used for lu matrix decomposition it's
not the most efficient but it's very
simple to fill it up in 15 lines or so
on the left here we have python no
semicolons this time in the middle we
have octave octave is a free version of
matlab but it's way way slower and on
the right we have 495. all the codes are
very similar octave finishes programming
first i think now that has the easy
syntax of any language
then fortune will finish second place
and close behind that will be python
numpy makes python very verbose to work
with in my opinion now for execution i'm
not going to average this out there's a
pretty big disparity between them
uh obviously fortran's compiled language
we have to compile it first
and of course fortran will win by quite
a bit
uh 0.013 seconds to execute python in
second place 200 times slower and octave
when it finishes we'll be even further
behind that
matlab will probably come somewhere
between python and fortran
it's way way faster than octave now a
lot of python and matlab people will
probably protest here saying hey we have
our special linear algebra libraries to
handle stuff like this
first off that's cheating you're
basically using compiled c and fortran
code inside your lang language but hey
i'll entertain that the only catch would
be that i get to use the same kind of
libraries in fortran for real apples to
apples comparison
so here we are coding up the cheating
code to make you nerds happy now that we
can be lazy and not have to do any
actual work it becomes almost trivial
octave again is the fastest and easiest
language you're programming
and then fortran and python will come
close second and third behind that
now to measure the execution
because these are going to be much
faster than the previous algorithm i'm
going to average these over to
iterations
and again spoiler alert is going to be a
pretty big disparity between them
so fortran way out in front 0.006
seconds octave jumps in second place
and python gets completely obliterated
not just by fortran but by some free
knockoff matlab thing yikes and honestly
i think python octave are cheating by
doing some multi-threading behind the
scenes but they're still so far in the
dust it doesn't even matter and that's
why you don't mess with fortran thanks
for watching